[Musique]
c'est vous autres qui avaient rendu vos
parents malades vous allez payer pour
vous et ils ont tenu parole
on parle des religieuses on dit
couramment les bonnes soeurs mais vous
allez voir que certaines de celle qui
s'occupaient des orphelinats de
Chicoutimi et de mondiaux à Québec était
tout sauf des Saintes
[Musique]
on a déjà eu un siège entre les deux
jambes
des enfants victimes d'une violence
extrême vont vous raconter ce qui se
passait entre les murs de ces sinistres
endroits qui ont déchiré son pyjama sur
le dos lui ont battu avec des cuillères
à coudre
[Musique]
orphelinat mais où sont ses enfants je
dois avoir la vérité à un moment donné
pour moi-même pour me
[Musique]
pour être complète
ici Marie montre Denis bienvenue à
enquête
l'ancienne orphelinat de Chicoutimi en
forme de croix rappelle la domination de
la religion catholique
les bonnes soeurs devaient protéger les
enfants vulnérables au nom de la charité
chrétienne et de l'État qui les
finançaient
[Musique]
mais ces murs de briques dissimulent des
secrets qui tourmentent encore les
survivants
on voyait pas école
[Musique]
pour nous autres
l'orphelinat pour moi c'est une prison
de nouveaux témoignages lèvent le voile
sur de présumés crimes commis par des
religieuses qui bénéficient d'une sacrée
impunité
[Musique]
grâce à leur voisin jouer les petits six
morts sont rapidement devenus les
enfants chouchous du Québec
cette publicité culte a d'ailleurs
marqué l'imaginaire
mais personne ne se doutait qu'avant
d'être pris dans le tourbillon de la
célébrité un drame avait séparé les
membres de cette famille originaire de
Chicoutimi
avait la journée soucis avec les deux
étaient obligés d'être hospitalisés puis
mon père était pas capable de s'occuper
de nous autres fait qu'on a été placés
qu'on avait une grosse famille mais
finalement on a été placé à l'orphelinat
4 des petits simards dont les Martin se
retrouvent sous la garde forcée des
Petites Franciscaines de Marie en 1967
René est à l'hôpital et Nathalie n'est
pas encore né
on était assez déstabilisés par la
maladie de nos parents qu'on n'avait pas
d'affaires
c'est vous autres qui avaient rendu vos
parents malades vous allez payer pour et
ils ont tenu parole la petite ligne est
battue parce qu'elle fait pipi au lit
mais ce qu'il a traumatise le plus c'est
de voir une autre fillette nue être
frappée sauvagement et on déchiré son
pyjama de sur le dos ils l'ont battu
avec des cuillères à pauvre
c'est clair après ça je me souviens plus
de rien c'était le blackout total je
pense que je vais marquer ce bordel mur
tout le temps je pleurais peut-être
je voulais me tuer j'avais essayé
d'en-tête d'oreiller puis respirer tout
le temps tout le temps et puis je me
suis endormie bon je me suis réveillé
pareillement
en sortant de l'orphelinat diagnostiquer
une dépression j'ai pas été capable de
passer par dessus ça c'était trop pour
moi
il y a certaines choses qui est arrivé
qui vont nous suivre jusqu'à notre
dernier souffle ils m'ont donné de la
salade de chou puis là la salade de chou
j'avais jamais goûté
[Musique]
de la salade de chou
ils m'ont rempli ça ce plat à peu près
ou trois quarts
il faut tout que tu marches
pas c'est pas humain de vivre ça là
non c'est pas normal parce que moi je
n'ai eu beaucoup d'amis n'ont jamais été
battu on jamais été magani
il y a Martin il y a moi 55 ans se sont
écoulés s'ils ont choisi de briser le
silence c'est pour eux mais surtout pour
les autres oubliés du système des
orphelinats québécois quand j'ai vu que
c'était pas juste arrivé à moi
cette fois comme moi fallait que j'aille
au fond des choses
l'amour de la famille Simard les a
sauvés et la musique a permis aux frères
et soeurs de croire en l'avenir Martin
en a fait une carrière pendant plus de
20 ans comme on le voit dans cette
prestation à la télé de Radio-Canada mon
frère
il laisse pas passer
la chance d'être
là
sauf que
sans le savoir ça nous a accompagné ça
nous accompagne encore pour l'instant de
ma vie tiens longtemps mais j'aime les
gens qui ont longtemps c'est c'est
atroce
[Musique]
le soir on était tous couché il y avait
30 lits d'un bar 30 litres d'eau puis
entre les deux il y avait la deux
petites
chambres des religieuses puis la nuit il
y a pas il partait avec une on savait
pas ce qu'il faisait avec je m'appelle
Monique Fortin j'ai été abusé
à l'orphelinat de scoutimi j'étais 12
ans j'ai été abusé sexuellement
[Musique]
avec moi Monique avait seulement deux
mois à son arrivée là-bas toute son
enfance s'est déroulée entre ses murs
[Musique]
parce que la salle la salle des filles
d'ici était aussi au bord on regardait
par les fenêtres du milieu
la bâtisse qui a aujourd'hui une
vocation commerciale à bien changé mais
elle conserve des traces du passé
[Musique]
ah c'est ça nous ligables dans
et mon Dieu Seigneur va nous coucher à
toucher un peu avant et après ça nous
couchait pas faisait ses choses avec sa
main bon c'est partout
rentrer son doigt
c'était pas plaisant
[Musique]
on a déjà eu un siège entre les deux
jambes
ah oui
les premières fois après ça
t'as pas le choix
t'as pas le choix est là avec toi
puis supposement que c'est la religion
qui demande ça c'est ce qu'elle nous
disait
[Musique]
je vous dis là c'était des démons
des démons avec des chapelets
ça vient me chercher
vraiment me chercher
je m'excuse
je me voile
monique a dit à sa mère a des bienfaits
de leur féminin et même à un prêtre
qu'il avait été violé mais personne ne
l'a cru et brisé l'omerta lui a valu
d'autre châtiments
la religion était sacrée et les
religieuses intouchables
le cas de Monique n'est pas unique des
sœurs pédophiles aurait fait plusieurs
victimes à l'orphelinat de Chicoutimi
des garçons comme des filles il fait
noir Lopez
une petite fille dans le lit
Denise rien d'eau révèle dans un de ses
livres qu'elle fait partie des enfants
qui ont été agressés à plusieurs
reprises des souvenirs qui ne l'ont
jamais quitté
un soir une des religions il est arrivé
dans mon lit pour m'embrasser puis là
avec fébrilité
flattait les fesses puis les seins
hurlais et puis l'auteur est arrivé avec
l'autre clé et puis
et le fait de sortir la salle mais c'est
moi qui est
folle de crier à ce point-là de
réveiller toute leur toit j'avais dit
moi vous savez très bien pourquoi ce que
j'ai crié
Denise a menacé de crier chaque fois que
ça se reproduirait les sœurs ont alors
tenté de se débarrasser d'elle en
l'envoyant chez le psychiatre
il m'a demandé comment je trouvais ça
alors féminin
que je trouvais soyez frais que je
voudrais m'en aller et un moment donné
il s'est levé puis là il y a dit au sort
mes révérences s'il y a quelqu'un de fou
dans cette pièce c'est pas cet enfant
la jeune fille a porté sa croix
séquestrée avec les rats privés d'école
pendant des mois brûler au deuxième
degré elle n'oubliera jamais le régime
de terreur des bonnes soeurs tout ce que
je veux c'est qu'il reconnaisse
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce qu'il y
a des enfants qui ont qui s'en sont pas
sortis
qui sent sont pas sortis mais pas du
tout
[Musique]
au retour des survivants se demandent où
sont passés les enfants qu'ils ont vu
mourir
quand on a découvert les cimetières
autochtones
dans les pensionnats c'est sûr que
ça fait deux dans ma tête
[Musique]
pendant qu'on tente toujours des lucider
le mystère des sépultures anonymes près
des pensionnats pour autochtones des
survivants des orphelinats de Chicoutimi
et de Québec se demandent si les
congrégations religieuses n'auraient pas
là aussi disposer de corps d'enfants
décédés en les privant de la plus
élémentaire dignité
[Musique]
finalement des bobines de
l'orphelinatchicoutimi
[Musique]
l'orphelinat de l'Immaculée Conception a
ouvert ses portes en 1931 jusqu'en 1968
les religieuses s'occupaient des enfants
dit illégitimes souvent arraché au maire
célibataires puis donner en adoption il
y avait aussi des enfants placés pour
diverses raisons comme la maladie ou la
mort d'un parent
ces images ont été captées lors des
visites officielles des archives
ponctuées de sourires et de gestes
attentionnés
pourtant ce même orphelinat aurait caché
des disparitions suspectes d'enfants
quand on découvre les cimetières
autochtones
dans les pensionnats c'est sûr que
ça fait deux dans ma tête
je m'appelle normande Tremblay j'ai
travaillé pendant un an à l'orphelinat
de Chicoutimi en 1962 60 et toi
les cas d'enfants autochtones disparus
ont reçu cité de vieux démons
normandes se souvient qu'elle prenait
soin des bébés à la crèche lorsqu'une
orpheline de deux ou trois ans aurait
été tué par une sœur franciscaine la
tête fracassée contre la brique il était
peut-être 50-60 enfin sur la galerie
puis moi ce que j'ai vu puis même
d'autres ont eu connaissance aussi c'est
que une religieuse a poussé une petite
fille après le mur c'est sûrement
involontaire mais le geste était là
parce que la petite fille elle est tombé
à terre puis c'est une religieuse qui
est partie avec leur entrée tout de
suite tout ce qu'on a vu par après le
surlendemain de jour la petite est
décédée est exposée notre lingerie
comment vous vous êtes senti
impuissante au départ parce que
on pouvait pas parler donc qui était pas
question d'aller voir la police
ça s'appelait ce que tu vois
tu fais ton le personnel religieux que
ce soit des prêtres des religieuses
tu regardais pas ça tu touchais pas ça
c'était un sacré
normande n'a aucune idée de ce qui est
arrivé avec la dépouille je me dis
aujourd'hui s'il y avait eu un cimetière
quand la petite fille est décédée on
aurait peut-être été à son service
il y avait quelque chose c'était très
caché
où est passé le corps de l'orpheline
selon les rites de l'époque chaque
catholique devait être enterré dans un
cimetière mais officiellement il y en a
jamais eu sur le terrain de l'orphelinat
une ancienne pensionnaire raconte une
histoire similaire
a pris le bébé peut le tirer comme ça
sur le qu'est-ce qui est arrivé à ce
moment-là
puis moi
qui vous est restée oui
ce sont
[Musique]
et puis je suis une survivante de
l'orphelinat de Chicoutimi
la scène d'horreur de ce bébé projeté
contre le ciment fait partie des
traumatismes qu'elle a vécu chez les
Petites Franciscaines
ma sœur pour moi c'était comme mon bébé
j'avais vraiment peur
j'avais peur pour sa vie Nancy n'a
jamais revu le poupon violenté il y a eu
des bébés qui sont décédés maintenant
ça je peux pas dire de quoi
[Musique]
je m'appelle Marie Podevin et j'ai
fréquenté l'orphelinat de 1940 tours à
à 87 ans la dame se souvient encore des
petits cercueils construits par les
enfants pour ceux qui mouraient en 37
ans d'opération il y en aurait eu des
centaines à l'orphelinat toute cause de
décès confondues selon ce rapport au
moins 23 bambins de 0 à 3 ans sont morts
en 1952 seulement et en avait leurs
parents
les parents venaient les chercher et les
autres
on leur fabriquait il y avait des belles
tétons blanches
puis on les mettait dans le sabre il les
exposaient des fois on allait les voir
et puis elles étaient enterrées je sais
pas où
je peux pas le dire parce qu'on savait
pas
Gérard Fournier lui avait 10 ans quand
il est arrivé à l'Immaculée Conception
sa tâche était d'aller chercher les
bébés abandonnés dans le portique de
l'orphelinat et de les amener à la
crèche et il a remarqué que le petit
cercueil utilisé pour les poupons morts
était souvent le même
temps on
voyageait
90 ans se rappelle d'avoir vu des
dizaines de bébés morts durant les deux
années passées là-bas
[Musique]
on est donc parti à la recherche de tous
ces petits corps disparus on a découvert
que les déchets de Chicoutimi a hérité
du registre des Petites Franciscaines de
Marie selon lequel les orphelins étaient
supposément inhumés dans le cimetière de
la paroisse et identifier uniquement par
un prénom mais les déchets qui nous a
refusé l'accès aux documents n'a pas
retrouvé leurs traces et dit ignorer
combien d'enfants sont morts
vérification faite auprès de la
corporation des cimetières catholiques
pas de fosses communes pas de sépulture
pas de pierre tombale à la mémoire des
orphelins les religieuses elles n'ont
pas voulu nous aider à résoudre le
mystère et on décliner nos demandes
d'entrevue
on s'est donc tourné vers l'Université
Laval pour obtenir la liste des cadavres
disséqués parce qu'à l'époque la loi
obligeait les établissements
subventionnés à fournir les corps non
réclamés par la famille à la Faculté de
Médecine un rapport devait clairement
établir la cause du décès
on a épluché les centaines de pages du
registre il y a beaucoup d'enfants morts
provenant d'autres crèches et plusieurs
cadavres envoyés par les Petites
Franciscaines de Marie de
Baie-Saint-Paul ou de Robert Fall mais
aucun corps de l'orphelinatchiku
qu'on peut pas trouver d'eau ne pas
gros là
qui pourrait expliquer où sont passés
les orphelins disparus quand elle
descendait avec la fille
elle aurait vu des religieuses
incinérées le corps d'une petite fille
fiévreuse morte dans le lit juste à côté
d'elle
du parti vers les 5 heures du matin tout
enroulé dans un drap je l'ai suivi moi
jusqu'en bas
oui oui je me revois
[Musique]
je termine puis petite fille que
j'en rêve
parce que
c'est Marquain parce que tu as toujours
couché à côté de moi et puis l'autre
disparu elle était brûlée
[Musique]
certains anciens pensionnaires
soupçonnent que les installations
souterraines de l'orphelinat auraient pu
servir à camoufler des morts suspectes
[Musique]
pour y voir plus clair on s'est rendu
aux Archives nationales et à la Société
historique du Saguenay qui sont situés
dans l'ancienne orphelinat elle conserve
des plans et des documents de l'époque
on en a souvent des gens qui viennent
qui se présentent les anciens
pensionnaires qui sont intéressés par
l'histoire de l'orphelinat il y en a qui
ont eu des traumatismes évidemment fait
que il voudrait avoir des documents qui
pour essayer de trouver quelque chose
par rapport à ça donc souvent c'est ça
c'est au niveau des morts des enfants ou
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait avec les corps
tout ça
dans la bâtisse il y avait un
incinérateur sur chaque étage dans
l'aile des garçons et dans l'aile des
filles
tu ouvrais le couvercle puis je voyais
le feu monter là je restais pas
longtemps quand tu mettais tes vidange
dans l'incinérateur parce que c'était
très chaud puis en bas où était le
monsieur quiche les pommes de terre ça a
été là que ça brûlait
c'est un gros feu lost c'était un peu
comme un
des grosses portes en métal
et on voit ici
sur les plantes on voit aussi que
l'usine c'est-à-dire la chaufferie qui
alimentait la bâtisse était relié à
l'orphelinat par un tunnel cette
centrale de chauffage avait aussi une
grande cheminée en brique
c’était tout le système de l'orphelinat
il y avait beaucoup de tuyaux c'était
très chaud
l'incinérateur n'existe plus ni la
grande cheminée mais la chaufferie
modernisée est encore là
on a pu confirmer que cette usine
débouchait sur un autre réseau
souterrain 3 km de tunnel qui connecte
une dizaine de bâtiments religieux à la
centrale thermique de l'hôpital encore
plus puissante est-ce que des cadavres
auraient pu être amenés là certains
survivants se le demandent chose
certaine des portions de ces passages
secrets étaient parfois empruntés en
cachette
Nancy parents se souvient d'y avoir été
amené à l'abri des regards mais le choc
et le reste subi a provoqué un gros
blocage je dois avoir la vérité à un
moment donné
pour moi-même pour me
pour être
pour guérir pour guérir pour guérir
complètement
battu et enfermé pendant des semaines
Nancy dit garder des séquelles physiques
et mentales de son passage à
l'orphelinat c'était basé sur la peur
complètement
toute le job va détester le job est
amener après dans son enfer
c'était pas correct
elle est à la tête d'une demande de
recours collectif contre le gouvernement
évite communauté religieuses qui a été
rejetée et qui est aujourd'hui entre les
mains de la Cour suprême malgré tout les
juges ont déjà ouvert la porte à une
possible action collective pour
l'orphelinat de Chicoutimi jusqu'ici
l'identité de Nancy parent était protégé
mais dans sa quête de justice elle a
voulu raconter son histoire publiquement
après la pause d'autres cas de mort
suspecte d'enfants cette fois à
l'orphelinat mondiaux à Québec
[Musique]
les orphelins du Plessis se sont battus
si longtemps et de guerlains ont fini
par accepter des montants qui jugeaient
quand même très minime par rapport au
tort qu'on leur fait c'est maintenant au
tour des survivants des orphelinats de
Chicoutimi et de mondiaux ville de se
battre pour obtenir réparation mais
surtout pour qu'on connaisse enfin la
vérité
[Musique]
l'orphelinat de l'Immaculée Conception
ne serait pas un cas isolé de nouvelles
révélations indiquent qu'il y aurait
aussi eu des morts suspectes d'enfants
et même la présence d'un cimetière
clandestin à l'orphelinat Durville de
Québec qui était tenu par les Soeurs de
la Charité
[Musique]
j'ai toujours appelé
chevronné spécialisé en crime sexuelle
mais comme il est incapable de parler de
ce qu'il a vécu à son entourage on a
accepté de préserver son identité
[Musique]
S
avec moi elles avaient la recette pour
produire des tueurs en série
l'ex policier a passé toute sa carrière
à aider des victimes et à arrêter des
criminels sans jamais dévoiler son
terrible secret
[Musique]
les religieuses nous disaient qu'ils
étaient représentantes de Dieu sur terre
une sœur et une employée lui en aurait
fait voir de toutes les couleurs
pour nous essuyer avec mes serviettes à
me demander de ne pas un cheval
une cicatrice à la tête lui rappelle
qu'il a failli laisser sa peau à
l'orphelinat frappé avec une petite
pelle par une religieuse
le saint [__]
que je voyais plus rien à cause du sang
appelle
un autre jour il m'entraîneau au sol
jusqu'à la porte mais moi j'étais
convaincu j'étais convaincu qu'elle
allait me tuer c'est ce qui serait
arrivé à un de ses amis attaqué par une
employée que les religieuses auraient
protégé
vers l'arrière il a perdu pied j'ai vu
ses yeux retournent
une mort de
ça tout autour de sa taille de ses
épaules là ça a été la panique ils nous
ont sorti ils ont rassemblé qu'ils ont
dit il s'est rien passé et vous oubliez
ça
une autre survivante du monde Youville
aurait aussi été témoin de blessures
possiblement mortelle infligée par une
sœur de la charité avec un gros morceau
de bois
je suis allée aux toilettes quand je
suis revenu j'ai attendu un enfant
pleurer il y avait une porte
d'entrouverte dans le corrida ou ce que
je l'ai et puis la petite fille est
tenue elle avait des coupes à criait au
meurtre
et là j'ai dit à reste arrêter et puis
elle m'a dit si jamais tu parles tu vas
avoir la même chose tu vas passer par là
et puis ça peut être long une coupe de
jours après la petite fille elle est
décédée
cette ancienne pensionnaire raconte
qu'elle a dû déshabiller le cadavre de
l'orpheline et laver sa dépouille
qu'elle n'a plus revu ensuite
[Musique]
d'ailleurs les enfants avaient peur de
finir enterrer ni vu ni connu près de
l'orphelinat
aujourd'hui un stationnement
3 à monter quand même un genre de talus
dans les autres ont regardé il y avait
comme des petites pierres
silencieusement parce que
on se disait
sur le
côté
les lieux qui ont changé appartiennent
désormais aux cieux début janvier on a
demandé l'autorisation d'utiliser un
géorador pour sonder le terrain et voir
s'il y aurait des traces de sépultures
d'enfants mais on attend toujours une
réponse du gouvernement
si le gouvernement
refuse de tirer
mais ils sont complices de ce massacre
[Musique]
les Soeurs de la Charité affirment qu'il
n'y aurait jamais eu de cimetière mais
ils ne savent pas où aller les dépôts et
des orphelins
[Musique]
plusieurs des survivants rencontrés se
battent pour faire reconnaître les
souffrances et les dommages qu'ils ont
subi
[Musique]
on connaît en partie l’histoire des
orphelins de Duplessis les premiers qui
ont été reconnus par le gouvernement
sont les enfants traités à tort comme
des déficients mentaux une supercherie
de l'Église et de l'État pour obtenir
plus d'argent de tawa
nous allons mettre dans la dignité
l'honneur
un terme à un épisode de notre histoire
qui est pas le plus glorieux en 2001
Québec a mis sur pied un programme
national de réconciliation et versez une
aide financière moyenne de 25000 dollars
aux enfants éternis
le montant dirigeois du gouvernement
d'autres enfants de Duplessis maltraités
et abusés dans les orphelinats ont été
reconnus en 2006 les victimes peuvent
toucher 15000 dollars mais à condition
d'y avoir vécu au moins deux ans si vous
êtes là moins de deux ans
2200 survivants n'ont donc rien reçu
parce que les critères du programme ne
tiennent pas compte des CV
Martin Simard plusieurs survivants font
partie de recours collectifs pour
obtenir justice
[Musique]
les 5500 québécois qui ont reçu une aide
ont dû signer une quittance qui les
empêche de poursuivre le gouvernement et
les congrégations religieuses même si
elles n'ont pas déboursé un sou
[Musique]
Québec pensait avoir mis le couvercle
sur la marmite mais voilà que s'ajoutent
ces allégations de mort suspecte de
sépulture introuvable et d'agression de
toutes sortes
dans cet article de 1964 la journaliste
est criminologue Alice poznanzka Parisot
parlait déjà d'enquêtes et de documents
ultra secrets portant sur des morts
mystérieuses d'enfants maltraités
les religieuses disent avoir exhumées
avant la vente tous les corps dans les
années 90 le scandale des ossements
d'orphelins retrouvés dans le cimetière
oubliés des sœurs de la Providence à
Montréal un terrain acheté par le
gouvernement a aussi défrayé la
manchette
[Musique]
peuvent cacher quelque chose malgré tout
Québec n'a jamais voulu creuser plus
loin ça semble une affaire classée mais
les murmures d'enfants meurtri sont
devenus des voix vieillissantes qui
réclament la vérité
après la pause des religieuses
québécoises ont tous fait des victimes
dans un orphelinat aux États-Unis
elles ont appris la torture au Canada
elles se sont pratiquées là-bas puis
elles sont venus ici
[Musique]
c'est un chapitre méconnu notre histoire
longtemps les sœurs de la Providence on
dirigé un orphelinat au Vermont et là
aussi des bonnes soeurs ont laissé dans
leur sillage des enfants brisés
[Musique]
été 2022 tous les regards sont tournés
vers le pape qui présentent ses excuses
tant attendues aux victimes des
pensionnats pour autochtones
de ton fils et nous sépions
heureux pour les Premières nations des
survivants des orphelinats québécois
vivent aussi de la déception
il y a pas juste les autochtones
là-dedans déjà fenêtres du Québec déjà
des orphelins du Plessis ils n'ont
jamais pu faire une vie normale par
rapport à ce que ont vécu en été et on
est toujours
de poussière sous le tapis
[Musique]
dans les orphelinats ressemblait à celle
dans les pensionnats autochtones
mais il ne reçoivent pas l'attention
politique qu'il mérite
c'est un prolongement du traitement
injuste qu'ils ont subi dans l'enfance
on est allés à la rencontre de ce
psychologue et chercheur scientifiques
retraités de l'Université Harvard qui a
étudié des dizaines de scandales
d'enfants abusés par l'Église catholique
dans le monde
[Musique]
le Québec est unique parce qu'il n'y a
jamais eu d'enquête publique
ni de justice pour ses enfants
du clergé
ni des communautés religieuses qui ont
commis des abus
ça fait pourtant des années que les
victimes des orphelinats font des
démarches auprès du Vatican et pris
l'église d'au moins reconnaître ses
torts
[Musique]
la SQ a enquêté sur 320 présumés
agresseurs qui aurait sévits dans les
orphelinats et les asiles mais aucune
accusation n'a été portée sans pour
autant vouloir jeter le blâme ou imputer
une responsabilité légale à quiconque en
1999 Québec présente des excuses aux
orphelins de Duplessis mais l'Église
refuse de le faire pas question
d'indemniser les victimes je pense qu'on
peut simplement
leur donner un aperçu en tout cas de
facilité un peu la vie actuelle qui a
pas été facile pour eux
le programme national de réconciliation
n'est d'ailleurs pas une compensation
c'est une aide financière sans égard aux
abus souffert des miettes de pain selon
un tueury
c'est insultant ils ont offert le moins
possible
juste pour se débarrasser du problème je
vous donne un peu d'argent maintenant
arrêtez de nous déranger
au début on ne parlait que des victimes
de 16 orphelinat et asiles mais on a
compilé une liste inédite de 115
établissements pour lesquels Québec a
accepté de verser de l'aide au survivant
dans le monde où ville et l'orphelinat
de Chicoutimi
je pense que le gouvernement s'est
protégé
les groupes religieux qui s'occupaient
des orphelinats au détriment des
victimes
c'est un manque de respect flagrant
compte tenu des crimes commis
à l'inverse il estime que la commission
vérité est réconciliation et les
indemnisations pour les survivants des
pensionnats pour autochtones favorisent
une guérison
un processus de justice réparatrice
c'est ce que l'État du Vermont a mis en
place pour aider les victimes de
l'orphelinat de Burlington à guérir
cette exposition montre en détail les
horreurs vécues par les enfants aux
mains de religieuses québécoises
de la Providence du Canada
s'occupaient des enfants
elles ont appris la torture au Canada
elle se sont pratiquées là-bas puis
elles sont venues ici
qu'on appelle les voies de l'orphelinat
Saint-Joseph j'étais la détenue numéro
22 j'avais 6 ans et j'étais prisonnière
mais quel est le crime que j'ai commis
à part de ne pas pouvoir être élevé par
ma famille
elle n'a jamais oublié cet enfer Brenda
reste marqué au fer rouge
elles m'ont attaché à une chaise
une religieuse me tenait la tête alors
que l'autre m'enfonçait une cuillère
dans la bouche
elle m'a frappé tellement fort que je
saignais des deux oreilles
j'ai été projetée au sol
elles m'ont dit de ne rien raconter
la vie des victimes comme Brenda a
changé en 2020 quand une investigation
de l'État a conclu qu'il y a eu des abus
sexuels physiques et psychologiques
pendant des décennies
[Musique]
maintenant tout le monde sait que c'est
vrai ce qu'on a raconté
on aura plus jamais à se cacher ou Aster
des disparitions suspectes d'enfants
demeurent non résolus faute de preuves
suffisante les sœurs de la Providence de
Montréal ont refusé de remettre les
documents demandés aux enquêteurs elles
sont niées toutes responsabilité et ne
se sont jamais excusés
plusieurs victimes ont renoncé à des
poursuites
je ne veux pas de leur argent c'est de
l'argent sale caché par le sang la sueur
et les larmes des enfants elles étaient
payées pour les protéger mais elles les
ont torturé
une enquête publique leur a permis de se
délivrer de leur traumatisme en
racontant leur histoire
une grande partie de notre guérison
c'est de participer au processus de
justice réparatrice et de faire une
différence dans notre société
ça nous apporte du réconfort et de la
satisfaction
[Musique]
la ville de Burlington participe à cet
effort en construisant un Parc
commémoratif pour qu'on se souvienne des
victimes juste derrière l'ancien
orphelinat
et
quand le parc sera prêt
j'aurais peut-être le courage d'y
retourner
je n'y suis pas allé depuis 55 ans
[Musique]
au Québec pas de monument de parc ou de
musée les victimes des orphelinats se
sent effacées de la mémoire collective
un peu comme les enfants disparus qu'on
a oublié les derniers survivants sont en
train de mourir mais bien des voix comme
celle des 6 mars sont encore vivantes
tout comme leur souvenirs d'enfants
de mes jeunes années
avec un peu de chance
un jour et je reviendrai
[Musique]
je suis certaine que le reportage de ce
soir vous a ému et j'espère que vous
l'avez apprécié on en a toute l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là je vous
donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]